[Música]
es tan obvio que es prácticamente
proverbial no puedes desir un huevo
bueno resulta que se puede más o menos
el efecto de la energía térmica sobre
las moléculas del huevo puede deshacerse
con energía mecánica los huevos están
hechos mayoritariamente de agua y
proteínas las proteínas aparecen
plegadas de manera compleja y se
mantienen unidas por enlaces químicos
débiles
el calor altera su conformación lo que
permite a las proteínas desplegarse
desenrollarse y moverse
libremente este proceso se llama
desnaturalización Las proteínas recién
liberadas chocan contra sus vecinas y
empiezan a formar nuevos enlaces entre
sí más y más a medida que el calor
aumenta hasta que al final están tan
enredadas que se convierten en una masa
sólida un huevo duro este
entrelazamiento parece permanente pero
no lo es según un concepto químico
llamado principio de reversibilidad
microscópica todo lo que sucede como el
enredo fibroso de las proteínas del
huevo es teóricamente un proceso
reversible pero Añadir más calor solo
enreda más las proteínas mientras que
refrigerarlos las congela Así que el
truco está en centrifugar lasas
increíblemente rápido No estoy bromeando
Así es como funciona primero los
científicos disuelven en la Clara del
huevo en agua con la ayuda de una
sustancia química llamada urea una
pequeña molécula que actúa como
lubricante y recubre las cadenas de
proteínas lo que les facilita deslizarse
juntas luego centrifugan esta solución a
una velocidad vertiginosa de 5,000
rotaciones por
minuto lo que hace que la solución se
transforme en una película fina Esta es
la parte clave la solución que se halla
más cerca de la pared gira más rápido
que la solución más cercana al centro
del tubo esta diferencia de velocidad
crea tales tensiones que las proteínas
se estiran y se contraen repetidamente
hasta que finalmente se rompen bajo
presión vuelven a su forma inicial y se
quedan Así cuando la centrifugadora deja
de girar la clara de huevo está de
vuelta en su estado original sin
hervir Esta técnica funciona con todo
tipo de proteínas las proteínas más
grandes con cadenas más complejas son
más resistentes así que los científicos
conectan un cordón de plástico a un
extremo lo que genera tensión adicional
y dobla la proteína
Primero este método de deshervir no
funcionará con un huevo entero en su
cáscara ya que la solución tiene que
girar en un recipiente
cilíndrico pero las aplicaciones van
mucho más allá de
descoco muchos medicamentos contienen
proteínas extremadamente caras en parte
porque conforman agregados complejos al
igual que las claras de huevo cocidas y
que tienen que ser desenredados y
vueltas a plegar antes de poder hacer su
trabajo Esta técnica puede ser un método
más fácil barato y rápido que otros
métodos para replegar proteínas lo que
puede permitir que nuevos medicamentos
estén disponibles para más gente más
rápido y hay algo más a tener en cuenta
antes de intentar
descocao es un proceso de cocción
inusual porque a pesar de que se cambia
la forma en la cual las proteínas están
conformadas y conectadas entre sí
su identidad química no cambia realmente
la mayoría de los tipos de cocción se
parecen más a la famosa reacción de
meard donde los cambios químicos
convierten los azúcares y las proteínas
en delicioso caramelo crujiente algo
mucho más difícil de deshacer Así que a
lo mejor podrás deshervir un huevo pero
Lamento decir que todavía no puedes desf
freírlo para conocer historias
fascinantes Aventuras en el espacio
exterior alucin filosofía las respuestas
a las preguntas más al azar que tengas
sobre tu cuerpo y más suscríbete a este
canal manténgase conectado y curioso